tutti ragazzi sono video sono fa vigenti
oggi siamo tornati su happy meal tanto
ragazzi non è così arm test cos'è un
testo perché c'è topolino la disney
bomber mi piace effetto della disney
bomber esplosione letale anche è
fantastico scorta zio non è io non so
niente con reti wired sei bellissima
opera vista è un po sul culo quindi
glielo ad una botta in faccia però
esperimento al gun effetto fatta
fatality shot io devo tipo sparare la
gente così sì devo sparare alla gente
così perché ci ascolta zio mi è rimasto
st pistola ten tieni lato perché mi
serve merda aliens green ai temi fa mi
fa troppo c'è la granata aliena questa
rai
ho visto la morte in faccia realtà zio
prendi la tuba che mi sta su questi casi
ormai vi servirebbe a me durante le
interrogazioni se devo essere sincera e
stato un fantastico
l'ultima granata mi serviva rock swing 5
dai facciamo questo è bello tutto
arcobaleno così vomito arcobaleni però è
bellissimo altro ogni volta che la
madonna ed
[Musica]
mica sto ragazzo mi sta diventando un
fenomeno cioè non c'è verso no mica
c'era un attimo non avevo visto il muro
non so perché io so che questo questo
già mi ispira al nome se lo fai sei un
dio tu non hai mai conosciuto il dio fa
vigenti che cazzo
cos'è successo regala perfetto è stato
veramente fantastico come cazzo è
possibile ct po prima mi si è
addirittura toglie alla seconda mica del
uk e la terza muoiono non sono morto
ragazzi non sono morto come che si
dovrebbe fare sta cosa scusatemi che non
ho capito io vado avanti e si cosa mai
così mai così ho preso ho fatto gol
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ragazzina anche cristiano ronaldo riesce
a farsi è stato di beta 6 farlo perché
ti può e bellissimo cd maestà è strano
più che bello ci sono nei così d'altro e
non ho capito perché lui che deve cadere
ogni volta bene credo ragazzi di essermi
sloggiato qualcosa però non so che cosa
dici se ho vinto è stato bello è che non
si riveli mi piace non devo dire sono
proprio perché oggi è tutto arcobaleno
regano non l'ho capito al burlando 220 e
devo correre prima che prima che quei
cosimi migli invecchino il culo mi sa
che ho perso per questi ragazzi è
alquanto strana come primi nati con ok
stavolta ci siamo è una cosa sì look
perfetto gli ho fatto perdere le braccia
non so neanche come ci hanno colpiti
ragazzi sono solo un camino solo camion
e l'epicità non fatevi da ho vinto ho
vinte cosa stai facendo e cosa stai
facendo al mio culo gli piaccio al culo
che sembra quello di nicki minaj
save the toilet questo questo questo ha
un che di l'ingegnoso tra l'altro va per
del mio cuore non puoi andartene così
non puoi ho vinto ho preso al volo
ragazzi l'ho preso al volto ed è un
giorno felice quello in cui viene
salvata la vita di un walter innocente
rock swing
faccio questo tutto tutto blu cioè che
cazzo cambiano i colori
io non vorrei dire ragazzi però guarda
make hubble
io faccio quello che mi pare che non c'è
bisogna sì però scott non sono entra
non sono entrato come faccio ok vi
sembra normale una cosa no ma ditemelo
ragazzi sto vincendo da morto non so se
è normale però ok ok guardalo qui ho
vinto ho vinto ho vinto preferì ho vinto
senza testa ma chissenefrega tanto di
dischi giorni non serve più la testa
questo te lo metti nel culo tu beretta
non ascolta zio devi capire che non puoi
mai vivo sollievo ma sono charlie duke
st cagata prima che si perfetto via de
bravo bravo sorridi perfetto tanto io so
che c'è quindi ho vinto per la felicità
mi in gruppo un tavolo fantastico save
yourself ora questa ancora ma basta gli
ok capitale dei chivas e ci mangiamo una
zucca insieme non se vuoi a me la mangio
io impossible cento per cento però
questo mi pia questo mi piace questo mi
sta piacendo dove sto non fate
fottutamente domande non le fate io non
ho capi non ho capito non ho capito sono
schizzato in aria come un deficiente
sono caduto guardalo e l'amat e vabbè ma
non ho capito io come jazz by the fall
ne faccio soprattutto qualcuno qui ha
ordinato un massaggio shiatsu è vero hai
ordinato all'inizio proprio senti ma la
gamba ragazzi non mi serviva quindi va
bene così
extreme ho vinto questi uomini che non
capiscono un cazzo
la dieta serve sempre la dieta sempre
contro 22 per questo questo lo faccio
perché c'è scritto due se non lo facevo
e allora vinco subito cazzo cazzo stavo
vince 9 academy no queste sono più
pesanti
no ho vinto
avete presente michael jordan avete
presente le pippe
ecco questo ragazzi oggi è tutto un
arcobaleno o vomito zoe non ho capito
perché però io sono un figo a cadere
così è la mia terra eccola la mia terra
è così alleniamoci noi che siamo belle
link fest pensa veloce io non ho capito
non ho capito che cosa è successo ma ho
vinto
credo e fichi skate questo epico quindi
lo faccio brutti volta ho fatto davvero
mica in genere ci metto qualcosa come
tre anni e uscì va bene cercata che
l'attacco degli squali cos'è quella fare
ragazzi non ho capito oyeah che centro
devo andare che è bello che cos'era
quello schifo ragazzi già el'aveva beh
dai che cos'è ma non è uno squalo e
godzilla
vabbè non l'ho capito no no cosa stai
facendo non la bandiera giapponese
succede così perché io sto andando
storto
ragazzi io io guido che se va bene siamo
arrivati a casa mi ha praticamente ok a
casa mia ci sono i piranha certo ma
ovviamente lo hanno capito perché la
barca riesce ad andare storta sull'erba
spiegatemi che cosa c'è di ninja questo
livello a partenio epico salto ok eccolo
l'ho preso ragazzi oddio lo disse
disossato in una mossa incredibile
ragazzi mi stanno arrivando addosso
delle persone aiuto dalla mia vista
perfetta
fatemi capire ma io devo c'era un tizio
ma non c'era all'inizio sto tizio vabbè
io sono diventato un unicorno sono
diventato più unicorno adesso sono
diventato 2 unicorni 3 unicorni tutti 64
giants world trade trek cosa è già
ragazzi sta cosa è lunga quasi quanto il
mio caso quanto il mio caro amico non sa
che sta davanti qui che bello ma è
normale suo livello
madonna che poi mi chiedo disintegrati
recapitare disastro unpercento prossimo
l'amico mio tu non sai con chi stai
parlando
la più labili face à face smashing che
il terminato questo devo farlo troppo
bene gli ho fatto male spaccarti la
faccia
eccolo di perth e adesso se proviamo
ragazzi vedere se ci sono livelli miei
perché fa vj impossible game no che se
lo faccio ma perché allora ragazzi
dovete capire una cosa per fallara fermi
natio perché fate l'impossible perché se
sapete che io vinco perché non sa
fottutamente capitemi regala come no che
cazzo sovra dicendomi che sa come sono
rimasto in bilico se ciò fattaccio fatta
[ __ ] ce lo faccio adesso chat non
ce l'ho fatta però è più difficile ma
perché i miei livelli ragazzi non riesco
a far non c'è verso cazzo perché cosa
sta perché c'è la gamba al posto del
bene perché la gamba ce l'ho in testa
cosa sta succedendo che cosa succede
devo capire una che ti fa capire cosa si
è fatto hanno vinto ha vinto vabbè dai
va bene anche così io non ho parole sì
sì sì c'è un fa vince questo cioè un
livello con un nome è pieno di
significato faccio questo profit per me
che figo cioè dove perinti andare giù
bello domandino a facili na sulle
potenze attenzione ma che cazzo mi fai
domande mentre quanto fa 9 alla quinta
mi sta prendendo per il culo cioè a 5 è
questo qua 59 mila euro che i amico mio
marchio fendi se ti chiedo perché cioè
io non l'ho capita vedendo noi li
mortacci secco lo presta volta l'ho
presa ok ok premi space entra nella
famiglia immobile mi sarebbe anche
piaciuto ma è evidente come sto messo
direi che non c entra devo andare nella
famiglia immobile perfetto
mi spiegate con quale motore funziona
sta roba non lo voglio sapere non
spiegatemelo più è stato veramente
piccola cappella lascio perdere perché
strano ma proprio strano giocare i
livelli vostri oggi però va bene anche
ragazzi servito è piaciuto ma sotto un
commento mi piace anche a pace di
facebook e come non mi vidotto la tana
descrizione forse dovresti discrete rich
vediamo un prossimo video
niente niente porca la più bella ciao
bella ragazza